on a dans nos classes les armes
secondaires
comme expression me lisent analphabètes
fonctionnels qui ont des difficultés à
percevoir l'ironie par exemple le sens
figuré les étudiants sont mal équipés
pour rentrer dans un take décortiqué
analysé un texte s'il est vraiment il
vient accompagner le chef comme certains
ont la bosse des maths cloud et
saint-pierre à de la facilité en
français alors elle accompagne d'autres
étudiants aux caf le centre des dents
français j'en ai dû 8 par semaine donc
c'est une heure par les uns c'est au
cégep édouard montpetit qu'est né le
premier caf il y à 35 ans l'aide qu'on y
donne est plus essentielle que jamais
jacob lizotte apprend à corriger ses
textes à bages un problème de dyslexie
la façon dont que je veux relais metex
un jour être plus minutieux jour les
phrase par phrase pour bien m'assurer
que la syntaxe est bonne même pour ceux
qui n'ont pas de troubles spécifiques
la jeune tutrice constate un problème
avec les connaissances de base chez ses
camarades étudiants et un certain
décalage en faisant une petite erreur
j'avoue j'étais surprise par certains de
mes élèves elle le niveau de français
moi je me suis aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on arrive aux cégeps ont
atteint un certain niveau de langue il
n'y a pas que l'orthographe et la
syntaxe qui préoccupent les professeurs
de littérature et de philosophie au
collégial je vois des difficultés sur le
plan de la lecture je pense que les
générations qui ont grandi avec les
réseaux sociaux la technologie et
internet et tout ça je pense qu'ils sont
qui ont plus de difficultés à lire des
longs textes c'est plus difficile
aujourd'hui de mettre au programme notre
dame de paris ou madame bovary que ça
l'était ya 30 ans chaque session le caf
du cégep édouard montpetit suis près de
300 étudiants
c'est terrible à 17 ans alors qu'on a
une grille de cette cour qu'on arrive au
cégep et là en plus de devoir faire un
effet de rattrapage de ce qui aurait dû
se faire de manière répétée et
compulsive pendant 11 ans
l'apprentissage de la langue c'est ça il
faudrait que les étudiants arrivent au
cégep sache lire décrit fort capable de
s'exprimer ils sont capables de
s'exprimer dans une langue ni les
étudiants arrivent au sujet avec des
troubles des manques je parle pas des
exceptions le dans l'accord du participe
passé ou autre règle byzantine on s'est
vraiment des choses essentielles qui
viennent faire en sorte qu'on peut qu'on
puisse comprendre un texte confondent un
pronom possessif et une pointe à 1
prenant 1 démonstratif ça change le sens
du texte on doit écrire davantage qu'on
devait écrire il ya 20 30 ou 40 ans
alors il faudrait normalement être
meilleur en écriture qui lie à 20 30 ou
40 ans pour celle qui dirige la faculté
des sciences de l'éducation de
l'université de montréal le problème
c'est que la maîtrise du français ne
s'améliore pas on peut obtenir son
diplôme d'études secondaires en
commettant 28 erreur dans un texte de
500 mo donc si on veut s'améliorer ya
vraiment de la classe il me semble là on
sait que les élèves sont plutôt doués
pour organiser leurs idées dans un texte
et met un contenu approprié la houle bob
l'air c'est vraiment la maîtrise la
langue plus spécifiquement de
l'orthographe à l'université comme au
cégep les étudiants doivent mettre en
application les règles et les
connaissances acquises au primaire et au
secondaire
le département de linguistique de l'uqam
offre plusieurs cours de
perfectionnement du français aux
étudiants inscrits à divers programmes
et aux étudiants libres dans mon père
c'est du rattrapage pillaient des choses
que j'apprends ce moment que j'attends
différemment que j'ai pas du tout appris
quand j'étais jeune on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de notions qui avaient été soit
pas vu ou oubliés depuis le secondaire
par exemple une subordonnée rôle actif
la chose dont je parle pourquoi est-ce
que je peux pas dire la chose que je
parle il faut les outiller les étudiants
à tirer profit des ouvrages de référence
j'inclus correcteurs là dedans pour être
capable d'améliorer leur test de se
poser les bonnes questions quand ils
écrivent on adore les dictionnaires nous
les professeurs de français parce qu'ils
nous aident réellement à corriger nos
erreurs et on en apprend tous les jours
même même quand on est prof de français
depuis longtemps les étudiants forts
sont toujours aussi fort probablement
plus fort mais si le milieu de peloton
où la ccc la moyenne qui perd du terrain
le rapport commandé par la ministre n'a
cannes en septembre sur la maîtrise du
français aux études supérieures risque
de décevoir le milieu s'il ne porte pas
aussi sur l'enseignement du français au
primaire et au secondaire